[Applause]
a lot to talk about
lots of talk about lots to talk about um
a lot of things have happened
where do we begin man where do you where
do you want to where do you want to
begin topics
topics why we could talk about jake paul
that's where i think we should start
that's i feel like that's for you that
brings all your worlds together
bro how unplugged do you feel from the
world with this late
like like no like just after like the
[ __ ] past three weeks
four weeks like i don't even know
anything that's happened i'm reading
some of these stories i'm like that
happened yeah
yeah where was i [ __ ] i still don't know
what day it is yeah that dude
i really don't i thought today was
saturday
it's wednesday i was working out today
thinking it was saturday the literally
the
the trainer goes so we're gonna see you
guys saturday i'm like like a week from
now he goes no that's like a few days
from now and i was just like nah man
like i gotta play off that i'm that
detached from the world but
man [ __ ] has been crazy okay so we can
talk about jake paul um
we talk about chappelle also oh yeah um
you got to talk about
uh logan mayweather logan mayweather
yeah let's talk about jake
let's talk about jake first and jake and
nate robinson i was very impressed with
jake
yeah the kid can actually box yeah and
um
this is what i've been trying to explain
to a lot of [ __ ] in a boxing
match not a street fight you know who
might win a street fight between nate
and jake nate he literally just he might
win that street fight
in a street fight you have two punches
thrown
and then people grab each other and then
it becomes a wrestling match
generally speaking right because if you
notice the beginning of the fight
a puncher thrown then they're hugging
each other the ref breaks it up ain't no
rep breaking you up in a street fight
once you hug in somebody it's who's got
more brute strength or who's got more
like wrestling or jiu jitsu that kind of
[ __ ]
is going to the ground but a boxing
match whoever has more experience
boxing is going to win that yeah okay
because a non-boxer usually can't throw
a punch hard enough to concuss somebody
mm-hmm and if they can it's this big
looping punch and anybody who's been in
the ring is not getting caught by one of
those punches right
the reason is boxing when you're in a
fight right you're you're learning how
to throw punches you're learning how to
do all these things but you're also
learning how to be
comfortable in a wildly uncomfortable
situation
yeah it's a sauna okay and the more
comfortable you are in that situation
the more the more of an advantage an
extreme advantage that you have
right nate was freaking out in there he
didn't know what the [ __ ] did
i actually think nate got knocked out
during uh sparring
for preparation for the fight because
what do you mean
his confidence that is the most
confident athlete i've ever seen nate
robinson
he's five foot nine and he was trying to
dunk on nba athletes
nobody he was afraid of nobody he
thought on every team he was on he
should be taking every single shot
and he walked into that ring terrified
even before he's like
i'm not just gonna lay down i'm going to
go out there and fight and say why are
you talking as if you're the underdog
yeah you're the athlete you're the young
champion everybody thinks you're going
to win
but you're speaking as if you think
you're going to lose he did lay down
though he later
ready he went in there he um
had a tight disadvantage had a reach
disadvantage so he's probably looking at
himself
also like an experience he's had a
height disadvantage to reach this
advantage his entire life
and he's looking at this kid like he's
some disney star and to be fair to nate
there's no video outside the sparring
footage that came out recently of jake
paul doing anything that's like
really damaging in the ring then that
sparring footage came out
and the kid can [ __ ] throw like
knockout power is knockout power
he's not the same one who fought that
ksi dude that's his brother
so he's in there and boxing again like
i'm saying you were in an
uncomfortable situation the more more
comfortable you can be in that situation
the greater advantage you have
and to jake's credit he caught him all
three times with step
back overhand rights they're counter
punches what happens when
you're there's an unskilled boxer is you
often like lunge at your opponent
right so what they'll teach you to do is
take a quick step back and then throw
off in a straight right but he threw
this overhand right every single time
caught him
that is a move of strategy and technique
that's not luck
he called him three times same punch he
knew exactly what he was doing he
executed on it and you got to give
credit to that [ __ ] and i'll be
honest
if i'm him i'm calling out and he kind
of did this recently i'm calling out
every
you have to call it specific genre of
folks you have to call people who
are famous enough to
non-boxing fans yeah but not youtubers
right if the fight is just on youtube
logan paul ksi
the world doesn't care it will do great
numbers people will be into it
but the world doesn't talk about it you
go after
an athlete or musician that are famous
to the world and usually athlete the
only musicians you could really go after
would have to be like
super thug gangsters yeah because that's
like you're
testing their gangster in a way like if
you're going after john mayer no one's
going to give a [ __ ] right
right but if you if you call out antonio
brown
oh you know what i mean athletes you
always gonna side with the athlete
because you're like well they're an
athlete
they have this incredible athleticism
antonio brown be hitting people too he
got a history of abuse
antonio brown's getting knocked the [ __ ]
out you've been getting knocked
out for a while too real that's right
that's not gonna be the first time
you're gonna be late
i'll say this he got so much ct he'll
probably walk through a concussion like
a zombie yeah that's like a [ __ ]
white walker
just keep coming at you so i really
think
i really think if jake fights anybody
who doesn't have any experience
specifically boxing i think that he
knocks him out or he
at least beats them in potentially a
boring fight to that end while we're
talking about the paul brothers do you
want to talk about jamil hill and
uh they asked a joking question like
jamila hill asked this joke and asked
question
when she was interviewing jake she's
like was it racist that you knocked him
out now she asked if she's just kidding
so is carrie champion they're both
kidding because carrie followed up with
the same question
okay because i thought she got when she
was like why is that a stupid question
when
jake paul was clearly annoyed i was like
she's either trolling him which is odd
and seems out of character for her
right or she's getting a little annoyed
that he's getting annoyed and she was
like going to make it a real thing now
yeah
the thing is like i don't know if jamila
hill
has the equity built up to ask a
question like that as a joke
because that's literally what she does
for a living yeah is
kind of ask those questions like she
wakes up in the morning and then she's
like
it's racist today where's it at yeah you
know what i mean so why is it racist why
is it cold out in summer is that yeah
these are the guys on the beach with the
thing and the
the headphones and that melody the metal
detector
racism detector on twitter all the time
so that's her thing and i get it man
it's like you lean into what pays the
bills yeah and i'm sure like she's
you know achieved a lot of success like
leaning into that but
um eventually you got to be careful that
you don't become a caricature of
yourself
yeah like in order to keep your audience
honest
it's important to challenge them at
least that's what i think so
because if you don't then you're just
kind of caught up in this like
positive feedback loop but you have to
go more and more extreme in order to get
that same reaction
right so it's like oh okay so we called
this racist well i've already done that
what's what's not racist but is so i
thought this was her kind of trying to
pivot out of becoming that caricature
yeah and people weren't having it they
were just like no she's got to be
serious this is jamil hill
yeah i know she's joking yeah but this
is what you do
so now all of a sudden you're a comedian
yeah
it's and also it's corny boy you cried
wolf yeah
that's it that is it it was just corny
bro it's like
nate called out jake if jake was out
there calling out nate and he was like
i'm gonna beat your black ass and all
this other [ __ ] like he tried to make it
a little racist in some way sure but
like
you're literally only saying this
because the kid's white yeah yeah
and i thought he handled it well too he
was like come on yeah
what are you doing yeah yeah you should
you should have said yeah it's racist
it's racist the black guy asked if he
could beat the [ __ ] out of me
and i decided to defend myself yeah so
it's yeah he is racist
and nate robinson is racist if dave
robertson like black people
he wouldn't have gotten a slept like
that's super racist
for him not to fight for y'all he let us
down so
did you feel let down yeah really really
like at least
put up somewhat of a fight i don't know
he was just running in there
are you hands down like head first like
are you aware how much black people
think they could beat up every white
person is that a thing you're aware of
is that true yeah absolutely yeah really
yeah living with black people they
really don't think there's a single
white person on earth they couldn't beat
up
why things worked out the way
this is a new phenomenon what's going on
is that for real it's a real thing
really it's a real thing yeah that's
fascinating yeah
yeah you re-evaluate your whole life
it's like astonishing to me my old
roommate he was a big dude but he was
legit like i could take like five or six
of them
like the way i talk about fighting like
nine-year-olds yeah that's how he talked
about fighting white people his own age
i never thought it was that i thought
that they were like white people they're
just afraid of black black people
because they have like
a bigoted view of black people right so
like there are white people that just
wouldn't fight a black guy yeah because
of their own bigotry yeah
right but i never knew black people just
thought they could beat up every white
guy yeah yeah they think it was like
dancing
yeah interesting like that's
the dancing i believe that's the
difference we think
we have and what did this fight do to
that you think
i mean they could get them
yeah and nate is an athlete so he can
pick [ __ ] up killed his reputation yeah
and they got around he rolled with it
though
he leaned into the jokes he had his fun
was just like back on twitter
taking it i would have been in [ __ ]
hiding yeah he said something on
instagram the next day that was just
like acknowledging you've been hiding
for real
yeah bro i'd have been quarantined again
yeah you'd have to be in a dark room for
probably six or seven days
yeah yeah yeah like that just wait till
symptoms go away
come back outside 10 days i'm surprised
actually
oh boy okay what else we got going on
guys what else is happening
matthew mcconaughey called out the
liberals keep scrolling if you want
what's matthew mcconaughey up to is he
trying to podcast or something he's i
think he
wants to get into politics yeah there's
something he's pivotal he's doing did he
say he's gonna try to run for something
he's doing politics i knew there's
something he might try to run for texas
governor
that's what it was a brilliant way to
get votes in texas
to call out yeah and to say um he says
i'm aggressively centrist that's the
term he uses
and then he called out you guys don't
know he called out basically hollywood
liberals
who are making fun of republicans who
won't accept the election results yeah
and he's like i saw
you this exact person liberal person do
this
when trump won now all of a sudden uh
republicans are doing it and they're
idiots and you're so condescending and
arrogant about it holy [ __ ] we've been
saying to be honest
right but it's also kind of nice to
watch a hollywood elite
call out hollywood elites you know what
i mean and it's like a good sign that
this is all kind of like all right this
this thing we're calling it out
yeah he's making a move a man i don't
know what's gonna happen hollywood bro
like i think that [ __ ] it's moving
austin buddy
yeah low-key elon musk is coming yo yo
a lot a lot of people come let me just
silicon valley on its way
goldman is moving to where duff florida
bro they're all moving to the red states
goldman goldman sachs not not
sorry goldman sachs that's just like
california's
gdp is always so high or whatever i
don't think
it's it's about to plummet i think
slowly like
big dogs are just gonna keep moving why
would you pay those taxes
and austin is the perfect place because
they have mostly liberal ideals
but you don't pay taxes yeah it's
everything they want do you think that
shifts the like the political paradigm
in those
places you see everyone leaving they go
ah we gotta pull this [ __ ] back
and then all of a sudden in like
california new york people are starting
to go
well [ __ ] i guess we gotta pull
ourselves up by our bootstraps
nobody's bailing us out i guess we gotta
figure it out ourselves
what if there's this massive flip that's
what i'm saying wow
everyone wants to live in republican
states
nobody does or you know everyone does
everybody does yeah and then all what
i'm saying is california gonna turn yeah
yeah that is interesting if you're like
a if you're like a california
like republican like nominee or whatever
yeah i feel like this is your best
chance
you know what i mean like if you were to
go for a politician you're running for
senate or something in california and
you're republican you're like yo
i'm not what's ruined it was moving
everyone out like
there's something that happened in
within this election i think people have
spoken about this before but like trump
lost but trump
policy didn't yeah a lot of people
became
open-minded about conservativism
and i think that this was the first time
that it all sudden became relatable
trump was so polarizing trump was so
divisive that like they weren't they
were kind of like grossed out by trump
the figure
but i think a lot of liberals were just
exhausted by like the nancy pelosi's of
the world and these like
full-life politicians that just
absolutely suck and they're just
mucking about with this system it seems
like they're kind of like using it for
their own personal benefit
or party benefit rather and i think they
can't became a little disenfranchised
with the left man and i would not be
surprised if you see
in the next few like uh what is called
the midterm elections i believe it's
called
i would not be surprised if you see
people start leaning right
man leaning right especially now that
the president isn't right so there's
going to be a correction
because of that right there's going to
be this like reaction
they didn't get their way so they're
going to lean super hard and try to
flynn is an indication
of that that he's kind of a moderate i
mean he's much more of a lifetime
politician but he's kind of a moderate
democrat that's the thing but
it's a rejection of the bernie [ __ ] yeah
right like
and i'm [ __ ] with bernie but it's a
rejection of like the aoc's it's a
rejection of the squad like even
democrats were like nah this is not the
thing that we like
i think we think democrats are just new
york and just la
and democrats are also the ones that get
you elected they're in the middle of the
country in the middle of the country
is only so left-wing they're not coastal
whereas like yeah aoc is everything
that's perfect she's perfect
they're like nah she's a little crazy
but i generally agree with the left more
than the right
yeah that's a middle america democrat
joe biden
hey i'm not i'm not here trying to
[ __ ] defund the police completely or
whatever i just want police to be a
little better and that's how middle
america feels regardless of how we feel
that's how i think a lot of middle
america feels
you